edmond peut acheter un véhicule tout
électrique de l'année et qu'on profiter
des rabais gouvernementaux en effet
depuis mai 2019
le fédéral offre rabais pouvant aller
jusqu'à 5000 $ à l'achat d'un véhicule
électrique neuf et le québec tout comme
la colombie britannique offre des rabais
supplémentaires pouvant atteindre
respectivement 8 mille et trois mille
dollars dès la bête qui sont appliqués à
trets le calcul des frais et des taxes
et voilà qu'elles m'ont trouve le modèle
de ses rêves un prix incroyable 35000
dollars à ailleurs le même modèle se
rend au moins quarante deux mille
dollars
il se rend chez le concessionnaire et
déception ils réalisent que ce n'est pas
une véritable aubaine car en réalité ce
véhicule coûte 48 mille dollars au mais
le commerçant a soustrait les avec
gouvernementaux et l'a annoncé à ce prix
déjà réduit 1
il coûte donc beaucoup plus cher que le
véhicule proposé à 42 mille dollars
avant les rabais comme le prévoit la loi
en effet au québec comme en colombie
britannique
la loi oblige les concessionnaires à
afficher clairement le prix du véhicule
avant l'application des rabais le fin
mot de l'histoire
méfiez vous des offres électrisante de
certains concessionnaires
je